so the first one is that humor beats
stress 80% of Americans say that they
feel stress 39% say that it's caused
from work that's a lot of stress and
stress we know is a negative thing at
least prolonged stress small amounts of
stress can actually be helpful and
that's the whole idea behind working out
as you stress muscles and then they grow
but chronic stress becomes a problem in
fact it causes muscle tension high blood
pressure decreased immunity it can cause
anxiety depression there's a lot of
negative effects of stress but if stress
is like a villain then humor is like a
superhero because it combats all the
things that stress does so it actually
opens up blood vessels it decreases
blood pressure it relaxes muscle and
improves the immune system so actually
to help you guys relax your muscles
right now I'm going to show you one of
the funniest things that I've found uh
recently on the interwebs uh I also run
a uh website called humors office.com
basically it's a collection of funny
things from around the web uh that's all
appropriate for work that kind of thing
you go there and have a lot of fun and
in my search I I found this next picture
and I think that it is it's one of the
funniest things that I've seen I cried
basically from laughter um haven't even
seen it yet and this is
oh actually there's nothing there
cuz Studies have shown that just
anticipating
laughter like we've had some people the
mere thought of anticipating laughter
also relaxes muscles and that's the the
value of a humorous organization or
being known as kind of a humorous person
your interactions with other people when
they find you to be humorous and are
anticipating you to be humorous helps
relax them and relaxes their muscles as
well I will in fact share with you the
picture again this is one of the
funniest things that I've seen again I
should warn you that I have a very
distinct type of humor that not everyone
follows but this is
it bottom says I hope you find this semi
amusing right I mean it's a pun you can
read the sentence two ways it's a truck
wearing Groucho marks glasses come on
how is that not funny right uh